so this is just a warning to you
trumpers
be careful walk lightly
we ain't playing with you those of you
who are soldiers you know how to do it
make them pay after those ominous
comments from democratic state rep
cynthia johnson
house republicans in michigan rightly
stripped of her
her of her committee assignments but
wait
someone's also coming to her rescue
i think that removing her from her
committees
is too far truly and
i've reached out and asked the incoming
house leadership
to reconsider that can you believe that
so the next time you hear whitless
whitmer opine about
taking the temperature down remember
she is full of it she's locked down all
common sense
imagine if a republican it said anything
like that well